at the risk of understatement Acura's
new NSX hybrid supercar is a fast
machine it's capable of a blistering 191
miles per hour and the keys to that kind
of speed lots of power and lightweight
materials sure but to make a car this
fast you have to go slow and precisely
this is Acuras achingly bright eat off
the robots clean NSX assembly plant in
Marysville Ohio just eight NSX cars roll
off the line on any given day in that
same time nine hundred Honda Accords
join the road of course robots do a lot
of the work this guy puts together the
cars space spring an aluminum steel and
carbon fiber each car gets as many as 11
coats of primer and paint shiny but it
isn't all robots human technicians spend
more than 14 hours hand assembling the
hybrid powertrain suspension electronics
interiors and body panels and they're
constantly checking to make sure the
cars meet the tight tolerances required
of a supercar no loose bolts allowed on
this baby
the NSF starts at 156 grand so you won't
be surprised that even finished cars
aren't really finished
before the cars are passed on to
customers they go through a battery of
final alignment and suspension
then it's off to the track play
riverbeds where the NSX is slow bill
pays off with a blast from 0 to 60 miles
per hour and I've got swirling three